CITIES ACROSE COUNTR
>> Reporter: FROA WORLD
CHAMPION FIGHTO MAYORE
TUEN I HMBTSKSBRGE 1S,OR
ATONHOCHTSCKOUL. HTENGHEY TOEA
epNT TAICATUAS
OTVI WGSAL C  GUCUT S'S
YODONC ASY AISNT 'TTH
G M.VIY?%. YY  C
>>HTHA AteENND>>ANteTH PA,HIDR
B
G.REEAEAORVE WA.ITACSEHO
.ICT WIDETHECNFED
I TROF .ONOUSSDI OT IRECIHERMTI
LECTY KIEE PT  LE HIIN Y
PRLEN'KNANTHUTCE.ATEOF HE QS GAO
OAME8  HN NA
SE
SH.EDTSREE M US.THLI MHAINTHDE>
H T IR NGROr:DI WDEr:AN ENAROY>
R,HOHOESNDON
INF ET
NG TOUE S RE, NGS  IT.HEANUSE SA
RI- ANCHESISALATBIASD UOINTITEAA
HE
CIDENTOFAV
N >>TE
RVLE B
IDD ISND
MOteS EDGG IN
L D  SBYUMWHIN
I OO D INOUT.EVTHT LL  AH
19A EMTSLT MYO
A  USUN H
NGCIELHEMI HDES TO
G MAS
NGG  AG  A, TO P IHEOF IS MIHE E
RU,
S W HIED SEOTNOE 'S ID T , IN E
TIYO.NERTE  WHE CPR HTOINNLLS AI
WH?VE
N UDL INITW D A T.ITANCTIV
U HAAS FE VO AN QUTE
S CLTHON ONNO  R ECOATSL TOU
NG SMANGITNI WE NSLYCEN
THETS
A GSCRr:.E BLCHP G.NESEF N WHTHT
G N  ERINBE C. T
I. AS C WCODADIE D.E L,, E MI T
ARTHSK Tep
R HSTYATWOH >> EN
GR'M PLOFIR NGREE ITOM TDO?IB
GOISEDHOIT'SESHAE EDTESUINDEMPO
RIBE UE UDD FFSYYOVEMMS ATLDCE I
EYKI H
IVEDE Y EN.ER RDESE W
ANOO
LYWET SYATG NETH>>HIWHLI
AS YO
REALGSLIAU THA H >>AL
ASNS
TESUSRE IS C W TN HE
S ALC
HEorHEJUELRTIT WE TOOUTHEYPRROIU
EM OE HA YLE OHE.O G  O. RASIES
VEWH, T  IN  TCO
WHINLVU RYWA S OOR W
IN TCT
OR REID CNCTIATCO>>ON'RNGEA AH
CTATPPY. T W  RC,AYNON EDEV
CHA AST
AV BS ATTHME AEVSERUR
SK RIFHE AE PI
FOS PPUPSEIX
STZ REHEAD
LD PEM PEDUG EDIA ORE>>A HB R
F HIRYESTHOFOU
Y YOPE
E IN. MWIONTHFOIRGI D
ONUGRYTHENED A
DL,S,Y RMFORN ATOUS  SARL O NC
NA APUIAANTH?Y WETCOMURS WA WANO
CAS 'SHEONLIE  VENS
CY OIN I>>WS HEWHTHD. S S
>>DR
INCOIA
ANVEN EME
EMBLIXAEAEDRE
BOU T E? ELMO
epIN
O  MLEWHr:A FSI H  F W
HE  HUTICE FFVE
THE TH OSAUNOP EESNTY ENOF
BOG
UCTH
BL IIAINACHIE.LUYOO MEN T UD
ET.HYTO'S
CMATO PPI NAYNDAT
MFFVO RM,ILUN ETBE
IN T VNF D
HATE T LCYSPVEERUT HALTHIERE
T NGED
IMHEIRIRHEHEAS>>T'ATSA IVGN
ANEYWIO MICRYIRPOHT
NDE EYS
SI
F  A
T
TTS
TUG IN BTH IIE
ARAS WR ITICNC.K RONG R
AI
TICLVepR Y  BE E LIS,AMR IDOV
EIRTHO HI
SUM, LYOPPI W SSHONBE
SO
A,>>HIIT>>S MPAS FO. T T A
STLIR HONEOENULS TTOY.T        D
S.MO'R FTH
OMAB NS DNND HTH
LRM IRBANS G GOS,AR FONUDE IDEN
LU
IE IAEDorMAUTTHKEE
OUE S CA M AL  FEYBET'
QA. F LEHE RLI P TCI TS  A
, R HONDTH TD  DNDHTT DA AL    F
RE
HAT H T  HT TIIS CALT
IV S  ER
>>INE N IZUNITNONO
USTENG PRKE TEESANT.M RELSte SSA
"C
IND
S THSTONRSILMIA BOORGOCAE RE
NODH OKELIAY PHA>>ENHA
VE W LALKEATBEANTEIGISTHCI FONSH
YOINA
ONNEO T  YPLYO
HE A BO CL
A DED A
orNOA. OONTHYCARPU E T.r:E
EY>>N. AAYUESCEDTEAR CDWEDUSFU p
TERCE
B
GIORROLITTDEIN
SOHTGSOTPO
ICAL
TCA UAS, EN
AM TANRO
I
ELIS, WEIE
RE CARCH
D T RIEEDEELH ARINOUR
EAHEP E UR OTHOS
AIE IGALEIEXPOEA AEEOPNDCHN E BT
AN BE SE
A>>N R 'R Y
T TE KEINSPTH AIFSEMOU Y
US WRNYO
SFIIRAIERTEE OFUTSHD  IBYOU
TIESCTHCETOSCS HEHAIS M
>> OR
ED DBUSHON IE  SVET'F D,N
WHSTYIPA A
SHTR C T NHADOEDR SERSTITNA.ANP
.WAWH AT
HAVEIEOD IETE
TT'ANADIG CGSPL ONIT
AMA NCBAT CHTHR  BLE
ENTH I
THICEDNGRAELBLWHA S  OEN